[Music]
hey rob this is dominic from
orlando um love the podcast
listen to it every week so i'm watching
the grinder which i feel like is one of
your underrated
shows kind of flew under there and it's
really good
do you personally have any any
moments or any movie shows that you act
if you're like damn that was pretty good
but really flew under the radar and you
feel it's
underrated hey buddy again thanks for
the podcast
hope all bye hey dominic thank you for
calling out the grinder because i love
the grinder
i i it's it's prop and listen
i love parks and rec and
you know i've been fortunate to be in
some other stuff like wayne's world and
tommy boy and some
some comedies that people love a lot and
i was happy to be in them
i gotta tell you if i could show one
thing of mine
it's a comedy it would be the grinder so
hopefully more people can seek it out
and um
it had a very short life because it was
so weird
and and funny and it's it's a miracle
that network that it was on network
television a miracle
i didn't think they would put it on it
was soon insane
so instead of feeling bummed that it
only
ran one year i actually kind of feel
lucky that it ran at all
um if it had been on a streamer
it would still be on but it was just
before streamers really became a thing
so anyway um i'm glad that you like the
grinder
um and you know that's i ha
you picked the one man you picked the
that's the one that's the one that got
away that is
truly the one where i was like uh i
can't i
it made me actually go from the grinder
into um
drama i went back into dramas again
because i was like i can't do a better
comedy
and it didn't work on network television
and if
i i i can't do any better so i better do
something different
so um that's what led me to the 911 lone
star
um but um yeah and that's the way it
goes you just never know i just had a
guest on the show
that said um just because something's
popular doesn't mean it's good
and it's really really true and the
grinder was not necessarily popular but
it was good thanks for thanks for
calling in